la 5e édition du Forum logement a
inauguré la nouvelle Maison de
l'étudiant l'université épaulée par le
service logement de l'agglomération a
réuni une quinzaine de partenaires des
comités locaux et des propriétaires
l'objectif venir en aide aux étudiants
qui sont à la recherche d'une habitation
pour la rentrée sur Saint-Quentin en
Eveline je recherche un logement pour
bah après être proche de l'UT mais donc
on est venu ici pour avoir à peu près
une une seconde chance par rapport à ce
qu'on avait déjà choisi pour su avoir un
choix le contact que l'on a eu dans un
premier temps avec le cruétait des plus
agréables et nous a permis d'avoir donc
l'information sur le sur le forum et le
le fait de d'avoir accès à un bon nombre
de renseignements de rencontrer des
enfin des des gens des personnes
différentes avec des solutions proposées
d'ailleurs différentes que ce soit de la
colocation par contre est-ce qu'on
partira ce soir avec un logement j'en
sais fiche bien l'accès au logement pour
les étudiants est de plus en plus
complexe des professionnels et des
associations contactées par l'université
étaient présents pour guider les jeunes
et leurs familles c'est compliqué le
logement il y a plein de choses à savoir
il y a des mécanismes à comprendre on
est là pour expliquer au public comment
ça fonctionne et les démarches qu'il
faut faire je dirais les démarches
surtout adaptées à leur situation les
jeunes viennent avec des projets qui
sont parfois un petit peu déconnectés de
la réalité on est là pour leur expliquer
quelles sont les ressources des
territoires et comment tout ça
fonctionne c'est vraiment de
l'accompagnement individualisé avant de
prendre un logement les étudiants
doivent toutefois attendre les résultats
du bac